you're fascinating the next two
challenges I think kind of go together
so I'll ask both at the same time which
is most of your locations are malls
airports and then obviously of
stand-alone as well but the malls and
airports are coming under pressure right
airports mainly from the köppen 19 and
less travel and then the malls just
because of the secular trend of like
everyone thinks malls are going away
yeah how have you dealt with that or
kind of what decisions have you guys
made to kind of address that mitigated
or maybe capitalize on some opportunity
there also a piece of that being like an
entire delivery you know explosion
during Cove at 19 I know you guys are
doing some of that out of the malls as
well so maybe talk just about like
physical locations and delivery and kind
of how you navigate so much to unpack
there so malls Auntie Anne's is our only
brand that's a majority exposed to malls
Cinnabons
even only one-third in malls the other
third are in Schlotzsky's another third
are in these like travel centers on
interstates so Auntie Anne's is the
brand that's the most exposed and that's
one of seven brands so it's actually
quite a small portion of our total
portfolio but it's a majority of this
one enormous brand that we have so the
last two year point the last several
years the trends of mall traffic
ecommerce siphoning off mall traffic
mall you know questions around malls and
their viability that's not new that's
been going on for almost a decade what
what is new is the acceleration of those
trends from kovat and from just the
increased adoption of e-commerce so I'll
touch on malls first and then go over to
delivery because the rest of our
business is streetside and so a couple
things are going on in balls one you
have different malls right you've got
ABCD malls they are what it sounds like
they are a super premium D hyperlocal
like center of the community in a
regional maybe even sleep your area C
and B malls have actually recovered
faster from Kovan because they are
centers of the community they're not
just a place to shop if a place is just
a place to shop it is equally the demand
shock is tremendous because you have
alternatives with e-commerce so leading
up to
one as you said was layering in delivery
even from our mall businesses and that
wasn't easy for a couple years the malls
didn't give drivings drivers their
spaces it wasn't easy to park and
navigate these huge centers so it was
clunky at first but it got better as it
became very clear that this was an
important way to drive revenue for the
business so it got better over the last
18 months being able to deliver Auntie
Anne's Pretzels via ubereats or door -
or post mate's which i guess is now
ubereats
or easy catering catering businesses but
that's still only a portion of
incremental sales the lion's share was
still coming out of the business so a
few things one is learn how to increase
the capture rate of the people who are
coming in fewer people coming in figure
out a way to capture your larger fair
share of the business second of course
then was product development and other
channels meal kits pretzel kits other
things that helped drive revenue so it's
looking outside the mall for the
additional revenue opportunities
including delivery and DTC but then
optimizing for what's in the mall and
then having a longer-term view of which
malls are gonna survive which ones are
going to do well as a shopping and
commerce center because they're just
that good like the owners are gonna keep
plowing tens of hundreds of millions
over time into them and which ones are
going to have to be meaningfully
repurposed as an asset in order to keep
bringing traffic and some of them are
turning old Sears into apartments some
are turning it into hospital and there's
a lot of really cool things you can do
with that real estate and if those
developers figure it out then there is
still life even in those malls for small
food tenants like our franchises and
then there will be some that are going
to go away so we have food trucks
pop-ups hub-and-spoke models there are
many options like you exhaust all these
options before you just say lights out
you know in a location and then remember
the quickest way to get out of a hole is
to stop digging so for the last three
years we've been opening more and more
street side businesses but co-branding
and tri branding so putting more brands
more day parts more occasions together
reduces the real estate investment risk
and gives us access to more non mall
options so that's the mall piece
delivery we were one of the first
national chains to sign up with post
mates actually post mates was the early
mover in the food delivery space before
ubereats and doordash really got
traction and we were one of the first
when they were only in 17 cities and so
delivery has been a part growing part of
our business for well over five years
but the last two years it has become a
material part of the brick-and-mortar
business then add to the fact that we've
been investing in our own apps our own
loyalty programs you know all these
things allow us to have a direct
relationship with our customers as well
as a direct way to serve our customers
that are something other than come in
order sit down
since we had that technology during
kovat we flicked on curbside in 48 hours
we were already testing it and had it
set up in some locations but because we
had made these investments we were able
to turn on different functionality not
just on the technology side but on the
operating model side that allowed us to
also launch meal kits and Moe's Market
and other things that kept us in
business even when dining room business
went away some of our brands have not
reopened dining rooms and are doing pre
Kovan sales just through pickup windows
delivery drive-thru they're not all
performing that that way but several are
so it's really interesting to think
about how this accelerated innovation in
some cases an improvement and
profitability in other cases we're still
figuring out how in one operation to
have all of these revenue channels you
know curbside and pick up and pick up
window and drive-through if they have a
drive-through and app orders and then
the 10 15 percent of people that
actually still want to come in
that's a lot to manage with a small crew
so we're now navigating the operational
impacts as all of that's converging and
you have the benefit obviously of having
to seven different brands how much of
the input
structured around the technology for
let's say delivery and things like that
is shared and you're just kind of white
labeling it or relabeling it for each
brand versus you're actually building a
different technology stack for Auntie
Anne's versus Cinnabon versus the others
it's a great question one day it will
all be the same but because we grow by
acquisition you know we get what we buy
and sometimes we get something super old
that's at end-of-life and we need to
upgrade it anyway and when we do we
bring it on to our platform other times
it's it's not old it's not optimal but
it doesn't make sense to tear it apart
based on the financial equation and
other things you're working on so you
just tweak it and other things we bought
Jamba they were at the very beginning of
a brand new technology contract and it
was just too unwieldy to unwind and so
we you know we had to work our way
around that but brand by brand as the
window represents itself we bring them
on to a common platform whether that's
web general digital commerce loyalty
apps and frameworks so it's it's a
journey but the utopia is common
platform so as we acquire brand you just
reskin put it on alter it for whatever
that business model is different
consumer frequency you know different
segments or pricing to your potentially
but otherwise keep building on the
successes so we're about halfway through
that journey